in the far and north of Ukraine there's
no cell reception so Maps lead us
towards the border with Belarus the
region of chernohe fell when Russia
invaded in February but in April Ukraine
took it back
this is Russian equipment they left
behind while retreating and there's tons
of it in our forest
we Patrol these positions this forest
and these are like trophies we're very
proud of the Ukrainian Armed Forces
this Russian cannon is now being
deployed by the Ukrainian military the
soldiers here are on constant alert
I think anything's possible because
they're losing among other fronts so
they might decide to start a new one
here
dimitro used to work for the railway in
almost nine months of War he spent just
two weeks with his family he has a lot
of anger towards Russia
because they've endorsed civilian deaths
If This Were a proper War it would only
be soldiers dying
but when a nation celebrates the deaths
of children during Air Raids disabled
children even that makes me angry is
also been deployed here he's just 20
years old
I'm in great physical condition
I'm a quick learner
we're not split up into age groups here
we all have one task
my comrades are between 18 and 60 years
old
we're all equal
this Ukrainian Village along the border
is afraid of fresh attacks the Russian
military is said to be just 30
kilometers away but hardly anyone wants
to leave
how can I leave I was born here I raised
my own and other people's children here
where am I supposed to go
pensioner Valentina has also spent her
entire life in this Village
she recalls the fearful moments of the
attacks early this year
we were attacked in February
that was a whole Convoy of vehicles
along our street here
we were so scared we couldn't sleep
night or day
and then at 10 at night they started
launching these bright missiles
valentina's children are in the regional
capital of chernohev but she's not
thinking about joining them
this is our home we were born here we're
not going anywhere
the Russians raided The Village Store
when they invaded in February says Anna
a sales clerk here
it pains her to see how neighboring
Belarus has sided with the Russian
military
we used to be friends with Belarus but
now I have a bad impression of them
they used to go shopping in China heave
and now they've made us their enemies
the men in the forest are preparing for
the worst olexy is a former veterinarian
with three children and three
grandchildren and he's fighting for them
my grandchildren have already learned
what war is
they know about shelling
they've lost friends my son is also in
the military I'm in the military my
son-in-law is
there's a lot to lose and you only live
once but if someone's hit it should be
me and not my children or grandchildren
the situation remains tense Russia is
conducting Air Raids on Ukraine from
Belarus and likely receiving Belarusian
tanks an attack could come at any moment